il est 20h bonsoir à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de cette fin de
week-end une semaine de plus ou pas nous
ferons le point sur les conditions météo
pour les prochains jours la neige de
froid qui provoque toujours des
difficultés de circulation sur le réseau
secondaire
la france qui n'est pas isolé une grande
partie de l'europe grelotte également
vous le verrez la martinique et la
guyane vote aujourd'hui les référendums
sur l'évolution du statut des deux
départements d'outre-mer sont en cours
nous ferons un point sur la
participation coup de projecteur ce soir
sur des attaques à l'acide dans les rues
de hong kong cela fait un an que les
forces de police recherche l'auteur de
ces coups de folie à répétition trente
personnes ont été à nouveau blessé hier
soir un suspect a été arrêté
nous reviendrons près de trois ans après
la disparition de maddie sur le procès
qui s'ouvre cette semaine à lisbonne
procès qui oppose les parents l'enfant
un ancien inspecteur chargé de l'anc est
celui ci maintient ses accusations sur
le couple britannique
un dimanche de sport avec les résultats
allaient prendre une deuxième de finale
de la coupe de france de football ne
sort de la compétition éliminé par le
petit club breton de plabennec la 3e
victoire en coupe du monde de ski du
français julien les
et puis nous ferons le point sur le
dakar enfin notre grand format ce
dimanche consacré un film pour
l'histoire clint eastwood revient sur la
légende demander la lune fiction plus
près de la réalité sur fond d' apartheid
et de coupe du monde de rugby qui
servira de ciment à la réconciliation
nationale en afrique de sud
voilà pour les titres ce soir merci
d'être avec nous nous allons tout
d'abord revenir sur cet hiver qui s'est
bel et bien installé en france on verra
quelle sera la météo cette semaine dans
un instant mais avant cela
commençons par des images allaient
symbolique elles nous viennent du nord
de la france vous allez le voir les
canaux sont gelés et ce sont des brise
glaces qui ont dû entrer en action
images étonnantes signé patrick du
ressort du reportage denis guérin la
banquise au beau milieu du canal et un
bateau un seul qui part à la rencontre
des autres prisonniers des glaces
la mission du bien nommé tout en est
simple à défaut d'être facile ouvrir la
route coûte que coûte
sous la coque du brise-glace une semelle
capable de briser jusqu'à 12 cm
d'épaisseur
mais il faut faire vite ce rond point
la grèce va s'épaissir et après ça plus
occupé la 4è sur le canal du nord
transit jusqu'à 50 péniche par jour
plusieurs centaines de tonnes de
marchandises qu'il faut acheminer même
au plus fort de l'hiver
et dans ces conditions le danger n'est
jamais loin pas ça risquant d'être
bloquées en cours de route au mieux de
l'autre mcaleer pape a débarqué
rien qu'en puissent quand on suit en
force trop là dedans poster une
déchirure
voilà pourquoi les bateliers attendent
avec impatience l'arrivée du tout temps
dans son sillage cet équipage va
parvenir à franchir quelques écluses et
à poursuivre son chemin un opus qui
périt dessus il faut le dire qu'on sait
on persévère tout le temps et on essaye
au maximum de faire de faire en sorte
que on arrive le plus haut possible à
destination la journée du brise glace
elle est loin d'être finie jusque tard
dans la soirée le bateau des voies
navigables s'est attaqué à la glace une
lutte sans fin et qu'il faudra reprendre
ailleurs dont le nord pas de calais des
dizaines de kilomètres de canaux seront
encore gelé ces prochains jours notre
trafic a fini par reprendre ce dimanche
en fin de matinée à l'aéroport de
lyon-saint-exupéry
hier soir près de 800 passagers se sont
retrouvés bloqués au sol en raison de
l'annulation de leur vol ils ont dû
passer la nuit au sein même de
l'aéroport
autre conséquence dramatique celle là
des conditions météo du moment si
probablement à un chauffage défectueux
qui serait à l'origine de l'incendié qui
a coûté la vie à une enfant de 4 ans
dans un appartement du quartier de la
belle de mai à marseille
une enquête a été ouverte soyez prudent
d'utiliser des groupes électrogènes ou
des chauffages d'appoint à votre
domicile
en bretagne on attendait avec impatience
aujourd'hui l'arrivée à à saint malo de
plusieurs tonnes de sel afin de pouvoir
enfin déneiger le réseau secondaire la
neige car provoque également
l'effondrement de plusieurs bâtiments
agricoles le point ce soir dans les
côtes d'armor avec le reportage d'eric
pineau et michel hiver il a tellement
neigé à certains endroits comme ici à
bourbriac près de guingamp que la
toiture de ce magasin s'est effondré à
la campagne on relève jusqu'à 45 cm de
neige une partie du réseau secondaire
est paralysé alors les agriculteurs
s'inquiètent
car la collecte du lait n'a pas pu se
faire partout ici aujourd'hui c'est 1500
litres d'eau legs que nous jetons par
terre par jour donc fait de fait de
calcul rapide ça fait 500 euros nets de
perdus par jour
tout aussi inquiétant les livres
d'aliments pour le bétail n'accède plus
aux fermes
cet éleveur n'aura bientôt plus rien à
donner à manger à ses poules une
situation pesante même la lourdeur pas
parce que on en rêve mais c'est notre
métier mais les manches ça devient
pénible dont le bourg la solidarité
s'organise à la fois dépanneur et
chauffeur taxi le conducteur de
tractopelles improvise s'entraide entre
nos sorts les voitures que l'on fasse un
petit coup de lame en venant beau faire
nos courses
voilà sept familles des 179
donc voilà j'avais 12 ans et l éventail
des neiges et office aujourd'hui n'aura
jamais à la neige on vous l'a vraiment
là avec nous en fin de journée la
circulation est revenue à la normale sur
la quasi-totalité des nationale bretonne
on redoutait un membre de celle
finalement les saleuses ont pu faire le
plein mais les températures négatives et
de nouvelles précipitations promettent
de blanchir encore les routes de
campagne voilà pour ce petit tour de
france du jour la question ce soir est
de savoir désormais si cette période de
froid va se prolonger dans les jours à
venir avec nous et isabelle martinet
bonsoir isabelle gossard le rang alors
on se pose tous la question est-ce qu'il
va continuer à faire aussi froid en
france est d'abord demain alors vous
savez le rang les sols sont enneigées
donc forcément nous allons encore
connaître de matinée très froide
demain et après demain avec par exemple
demain matin - 8 a ni moins 10 à
toulouse ou à montauban mercredi leur
dos va s'amorcer sur le sud sur le nord
en conservant encore des valeurs proches
de zéro pendant quelques jours et puis
petit à petit leur nova grignoter en
direction du nord est fin de semaine
prochaine
normalement on devrait profiter de
valeur plus confortable alors plus de
vigilance ce soir mais la neige alors
viens aussi le neige alors nous avons
arrêté deux jours ça c'est déjà une
première bonne nouvelle
chose oui la neige sera de retour dès
mercredi mais essentiellement au nord de
la loire et de façon moins importante en
moins grande quantité
ailleurs on parlera de pluie donc
moralité si la vague de froid s'éloigne
nous restons quand même en hiver
et oui c'est l'hiver merci isabelle on
vous retrouve juste après le journal et
s'attire glacial touche une une grande
partie de l'europe preuve en est ces
images en provenance tout d'abord
d'allemagne c'est le nord du pays qui
connaît les principales difficultés
notamment sur les réseaux routiers et
ferroviaires la plupart des vols ont dû
être annulés sur l'aéroport de francfort
et puis situation identique ans en
angleterre comme vous le voyez sur ces
images les intempéries bloque une partie
de la région du kent du yorkshire
le mercure est tombé à -17° dans le
centre il faisait moins 15 à manchester
ces dernières heures une question ce
soir qui fait suite à ces intempéries
certains semble s'étonner du froid et de
la neige en hiver
une évidence qui suscite toujours des
grandes man mais alors supporter on ou
moins bien les inconvénients de l'hiver
en 2010 qu'il y à 20 ou même 50 ans
éléments de réponse avec caroline
thébaux il junca et chloé cormery
regarder difficile d'en voir la fin
partout en france la neige a envahi le
quotidien des dizaines d'automobilistes
se sont échoués 14 degrés et ça fait
parfois grincer des dents
hier soir je me suis pointé à la gare de
versailles aucun bus ne rentre à pied et
ça me fait râler bêtement parce que mais
c'est parce que c'est pas normal que ça
marche pas quoi ça donne envie de partir
de france
un froid d'autant plus surprenant après
un automne ensoleillé le deuxième le
plus chaud depuis 1900 en réalité
question météo notre mémoire que souvent
défaut la france a d'ailleurs connu des
hivers au froid bien plus glaçant il y
avait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu
cela
- 10 - 12 en 1954 la plage de dunkerque
ressemble à une banquise comme le canal
saint martin à paris
à perpignan les transports sont
totalement paralysés avalanches de neige
encore en 61 au grand dam du postier
avec cela on a une heure de retard d'une
heure
mais aujourd'hui le retard pose problème
avec la généralisation de la voiture les
salariés habitent plus loin de leur lieu
de travail
neige égale bouchon égale retard égale
stress alors que les entreprises
demandent de la productivité comme tout
est pensé de manière un peu mécanique
pour que ce soit le plus productif
possible plus performant possible
effectivement le la contrariété banal
génère un stress bien plus important que
je ne devrais est dans une société de
haute technologie et de vitesse où tout
doit rouler une vie à l'arrêt semble
contre nature l'homme moderne est quand
même beaucoup plus fragile et qu'elle en
a l'air parce que finalement il ne
supporte pas ce qu'il n'est pas prévu ne
supporte pas ce qui survient et je
supporte pas ce qui lui sort de soin de
son climat moyen
finalement les jeunes sont sans doute
ceux qui ont le plus profité de ce temps
de l'hiver dans l'actualité à l'étranger
en bref tout d'abord la coupe d'afrique
des nations de football a débuté ce soir
en angola et elle se déroulera sans
doute sans l'équipe du togo l'équipe
devrait regagner lomé ce soir ce sont
les autorités du pays qui ont demandé au
staff et aux joueurs de ne pas
participer à la compétition et cela
quarante huit heures après la fusillade
qui a coûté la vie à trois membres de la
délégation togolaise
notre enquête ce soir nous emmène au
yémen le pays est en tête des
préoccupations américaines en matière de
sécurité depuis l'attentât manqué sur le
vol amsterdam détroit le 25 décembre
dernier
l'auteur présumé de cette action
terroriste était je vous le rappelle
passés par des camps d'entraînement
signé minutes alors comment ce pays est
devenu une base arrière des réseaux
terroristes revendiquant d'al qaïda
notre équipe s'est rendue sur place
voici le reportage de renault bernard et
de jacques dubos c'est un paysage digne
des mille et une nuits
mais derrière la carte postale l'ombre
du terrorisme plane sur le yémen al
qaîda ya tissé sa toile l'armée sur les
dents paradoxe le yémen c'est aussi le
seul pays du monde où il est possible de
rencontrer librement des partisans
d'oussama ben laden nasser al-bahri nous
reçoit chez lui
il s'est battu 6 ans aux côtés de celui
qu'il appelle encore le cher il a été
son verbe du corps le voici masqué à ses
côtés et il lui a même demandé d'être le
parrain de son fils aîné mon fils habib
est né à kandahar en afghanistan
quand il est né on a présenté un chèque
samo same as i la même date dans sa
bouche il ne la lui a fait tt puis il a
récité deux prières à ses oreilles
monfils a connu oussama ben laden avant
même de goûter le sein de sa mère
incroyable
celui dont le nom de guerre était le
tueur vit aujourd'hui à deux pas de ses
anciens ennemis
l'ambassade des états unis est juste la
maison ici on est voisins il n'ya pas
nasser al bahri a été pardonné par le
gouvernement après seulement deux années
de prison
d'abord le gouvernement m'a demandé de
ne pas attaquer les étrangers d'ici
deuxième condition je ne dois pas
m'engager dans un groupe 1 la troisième
condition a pas de groupes armées à
l'étranger non plus et la quatrième
condition je ne dois pas attaquer les
institutions du pays
le pardon ces combattants aussi on en
bénéficier les voici pourtant film est
de retour dans les rangs d'al qaïda en
octobre dernier mais pour le
gouvernement ce n'est pas un échec
90% de ceux qui ont été pardonnés
camacho abandonner al-qaïda 10 %
seulement sont repartis se battre ce
n'est pas une réussite
officiellement la société genedis ne
soutient pas al-qaïda mais elle est très
conservatrice elle obéit aux règles des
tribus qui la composent
en fait elle est très éloignée de
l'ordre voulue par le pouvoir central
encore plus éloignés des valeurs
qu'entend défendre l'occident
ces partis ont souffert en prison et à
guantanamo ils ont été enfermés alors
qu'ils étaient innocents
le terrorisme fait le sionisme pas
étonnant que confronté à de tels
discours le gouvernement yéménite soit
dépassée par la menace d'al qaïda
aujourd'hui un tiers du yémen
échapperait à tout contrôle du pouvoir
central direction hong kong maintenant
je vous le disais en titre un homme sème
la panique là bas depuis un an
désormais la police a proposé deux cent
mille dollars pour toute personne qui
apporterait des informations sur celui
qui a
multiplié les attaques à l'acide dans la
ville hier trente personnes ont été à
nouveau blessé et un suspect arrêté
explication hakim abdel khaleq dans la
confusion la plus totale les secours
versent des litres et des litres d'eau
sur les victimes pour les soulager
elles viennent toutes d'être attaquée
brûlés à l'acide
certaines touchées sur le cuir chevelu
d'autres sur les jambes au total 30
blessés dont neuf touristes et un enfant
de 7 ans la ville d'hong kong vient de
vivre en un an sa sixième attaque à
l'acide
celle ci a frappé hier soir la foule
dans un marché nocturne situé dans un
quartier très animé comme à chaque
attaque
c'est depuis les toits d'un immeuble que
les flacon d'acide ont été lancés au
moins une bouteille cette fois ci c'est
un incident scandaleux ignoble à la
police a offert une récompense pour les
gens qui aiderait à l'arrestation
d'attaquant j'espère que tous les
habitants de hong kong ont aidé la
police
la récompense est de 200 mille dollars
pour l'heure les enquêteurs ont arrêté
cet homme un chinois d'une trentaine
d'années interpellé après avoir été
repéré sur les toiles à nîmes le voisin
on revient en france avec la politique
est d'abord la confirmation d'une
ambition présidentielle celle de
françois hollande l'ancien premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste a
confirmé qu'il se préparait pour les
primaires pour lui je cite fini les
second rôles on écoute c'était sur
europe 1 aujourd'hui je ne suis plus
dans les petits rôles ou dans les
personnages secondaires
moi je les dis en 2012 je me prépare
pour être le candidat et je considère
que une élection classe et ça se prépare
longtemps à l'avancé pour à la fois le
projet pour le caractère de celui ou de
celle qui sera candidat et en même temps
pour la stratégie d'alliance et c'est
pas une improvisation l'élection
présentielle
de son côté julien dray était l'invité
de 13h15 le dimanche et lui n'envisage
pas du tout se lancer dans cette course
aux primaires
et voici les raisons qu'il avance vu mon
histoire personnelle mon parcours mes
origines
depuis le début je sais que c'est pas
quelque chose qui m'est ouvert vous ne
pourriez pas être candidat aujourd'hui
en revanche en deux
je veux pas ouvrir ce débat là je j'ai
dit ce que j'avais à dire je vois là et
puis par ailleurs c'est pas quelque
chose auquel j'aspire à ce moment de ma
vie
voilà pour les choses soient claires
parce que il ya vendre il faut aussi
parler de soi même moi je j'ai clôt une
séquence avec ce qui m'est arrivé
l'année dernière je suis pas candidat à
quelque chose au niveau du pouvoir
jugent plutôt candidats transmettre
quelque chose à des générations à venir
l'autre actualité politique ce soir
c'est le choix de la guyane et de la
martinique par référendum doivent
décider de leur futur statut de venir ou
non une collectivité d'outre-mer
on retrouve à fort de france valérie le
rouge bonsoir valérie alors où on est la
participation et canton et ratons les
résultats de ce scrutin
et bien la participation se situe dans
la moyenne haute je vais dire des
précédents scrutins à la mi-journée 18,9
pour cent des inscrits avaient voté
c'est trois points de mieux qu'à la
première consultation en 2003 et c'est
un tout petit peu en dessous de la
présidentielle de 2007
au total 297 mille électeurs sont
invités à choisir aujourd'hui oui ou non
un changement de statut de leur île
c'est un moment historique à me confier
un vieil électeurs ce matin qui voter
ici à fort de france et dans les figures
historiques emblématiques de ce rendez
vous électoral
serge letchimy le maire de fort de
france qui est contre ce changement a
voté parmi les premiers ce matin et son
adversaire alfred marie-jeanne 73 ans
figure historique de l'indépendantisme
ici à voter dans son fief tout à l'heure
a rivière pilote
il reste encore trois heures les bureaux
ferment à 18h heure locale 23h à paris
et nous connaîtrons donc les résultats
de ce scrutin au petit matin pour vous
merci beaucoup vallée la politique
toujours demain un hommage solennel sera
rendu à philippe séguin aux invalides à
paris en présence de l'actuel président
de la république et de deux anciens
chefs de l'état jacques chirac et valéry
giscard d'estaing
une cérémonie que vous pourrez
d'ailleurs suivre en direct sur france 2
avec marie drucker dès 14h45 on a évoqué
dans nos éditions philippe séguin le
politique le gaulliste social
on a parlé de ses paradoxes de son
indépendance ce soir non sur l'homme
portrait d'un républicain enfants de la
tunisie
l'ombrageux parfois et passionné de
football toujours alix bouilhaguet et
david da meddah c'était là dans ce
restaurant parisien philippe séguin
avait ses habitudes
et ici il était un client choisit le
plat tunisien c'est un pas comment j'ai
tous les tunisiens
modeste ou tunisie tous les matins et
philippe séguin chaque fois qu'ils
téléphonaient idées et que j'arrivais
nous on lui préparer ce plat
automatiquement ça lui rappelait
l'accusé tunis une enfance au soleil au
bord de la mer un souvenir obsédant
celui d'un père mort à la guerre en 1944
philippe séguin n'a que seize mois à 6
ans il reçoit la croix de guerre de son
père et puis la nation philippe m'a
toujours dit c'est le seul titre de
gloire que je revendique depuis la
nation j'ai été adopté par la république
il est tout le temps et les mutuelles
sont prises au public son estime inès
légitime ne sera jamais légitime pour
honorer le père le fils part à la
conquête de la france philippe séguin
incarne cette république du mérite et
gravit les marches député maire ministre
il est un président de l'assemblée
nationale ou en couleur
bonjour je recherche je parle de
philippe séguin
c'est un rire c'est aussi un écorché vif
et des colères légendaires de la cepal
suggestions c'est comme ça ils savaient
pas autrement
ah bon et vous prenez un meeting d'avoir
un quart étaient entièrement femmes sont
bien contents et si vous énerve
systématiquement
bêtise assidue sur les bancs de
l'assemblée comme sur ceux d'un stade
aucun d'abord très connaisseur du foot
très passionné du psg est très tezuka
dire qu'on pouvait rester une heure et
demie l'un à côté de l'autre sens au du
rameau après l'hommage de main aux
invalides philippe séguin reposera dans
le caveau familial dans le var les 20h18
à suivre dans la deuxième partie de
votre journal on reviendra sur la ferme
a dit avec l'ouverture cette semaine à
lisbonne du procès opposant les parents
de l'enfant disparu à l'ancien
inspecteur chargé de la faire qui les
accusent un dimanche de sport avec le
football et les 32e de finale de la
coupe de france les grosses en sorte
sauf l'ogcnice qui chutent le ski et
julien lizeroux qui brille en coupe du
monde
et puis le dakar enfin un grand format
ce soir sur un film pour l'histoire
signé clint eastwood à l'occasion vous
le verrez de revivre quelques images de
l'incroyable destin de nelson mandela
mais avant cela dans quelques jours les
lycéens devront déjà choisir en quelque
sorte leur avenir quelle filière quelle
formation
un grand choix pour un grand saut
parfois dans l'inconnu pour les guider
il y avait ce week-end à un salon à
paris reportage mallory ahounou et
mathieu dreujou ils ont rendez-vous avec
leur futur proche
l'après bat matinée pour y voir plus
clair les prix inscription dans le
supérieur s'ouvre dans une dizaine de
jours mais de nombreux lycéens cherchent
encore leur chemin
à les voir revenir des paris quatre
mandats chien avec versus un parcours du
combattant quand même le plus ardu faire
le tri dans la multitude de formations
proposées mieux vaut suivre quelques
conseils davies et ça peut ne pas se
censurer faire un maximum de buzz
cohérent n'ayant bien regarder les
contenus et en ayant au moins sûrs ou
une fois un rendez vous avec un
conseiller d'orientation psychologue
dans l'année pour faire le point sur les
résultats des matchs
apb pour admission postbac
le serveur qui enregistre la quasi
totalité des inscriptions depuis l'an
dernier un système centralisé qui
simplifie les démarches à condition de
ne rater aucune étape du 20 janvier au
20 mars
il faut formuler ses voeux 36 au maximum
attention certains établissements exige
des dossiers à renvoyer avant le 2 avril
il faut ensuite classer ses demandes par
ordre de préférence modifiable jusqu'au
4 juin étape décisive car une
candidature acceptée annulera les
suivantes
et mieux vaut ne pas tout miser sur les
filières sélectives comme les prépas ou
les bts
le risque est de ne m'être emule part
sachant que la procédure complémentaire
ne concerne que les places restées
vacantes
quand on s'expose à n'avoir qu'un second
choix
les réponses d'admission tomberont entre
le 10 juin et le 15 juillet mais avant
d'aller en école ou en fac il faudra
déjà décroché son bac et revoici la
ferme a dit la ferme à cannes les
parents l'enfant disparue au portugal en
septembre 2007 se rendront cette semaine
à lisbonne pour l'ouverture du procès
qui les oppose a lancé un inspecteur
chargé de l'enquète l'ex policier qui
estime toujours que les parents mccann
sont coupables jacques cardoze et
stéphane guillon
il n'était plus revenu au portugal
depuis deux ans ce 13 décembre le visage
fermé sans un mot à la presse les mccann
sont de retour à praia da luz lieu de
disparition de leur fille une douleur
aiguë jdir à kate mccann
mais ce jour là le couple est de retour
pour tenter l'interdiction d'un livre
écrit par cet homme une audience
finalement reportée à mercredi prochain
conte [ __ ] amaral patron de l'anc est
à l'époque est convaincu de la
culpabilité des mccann selon lui il
aurait tué accidentellement la petite
fille avant de dissimuler le cadavre une
thèse qui a fait long feu
les mccann ont été blanchis et veulent
désormais obtenir une interdiction de
publication du livre les spéculations
n'aide pas et plus les scénarios que je
peux imaginer deviennent obsessionnel et
ce n'est pas ce que je veux et ce qui
est bon pour madeleine madeleine devrait
être avec sa famille le couple a
toujours privilégié la thèse de
l'enlèvement et continuent d'évoquer
cette hypothèse c'est pour cela qu'en
octobre dernier avec la contribution de
la police britannique
ils ont fait diffuser cette vidéo voilà
ce que serait madeleine aujourd'hui à
l'âge de 6 ans il ya quelqu'un qui garde
un secret et ce depuis deux ans et ce
secret finit par s'effacer de la mémoire
de cette personne parce que sans doute
celle ci le garde par amitié ou par
amour pour quelqu'un l'anc est sûre la
disparition de la petite fille est
officiellement close
les époux mccann ont engagé des
détectives privés mais aucune hypothèse
n'a pour l'heure été jugée crédible et
si l'audience de mercredi peut les
réhabiliter elle ne leur donnera pas
beaucoup plus de renseignements sur ce
qui demeure un mystère
un dimanche de sport avec les 32e de
finale de la coupe de france de football
et peu de surprises du ski julien
lizeroux en pleine forme
un mois avant les jo et puis l'étape du
jour du dakar tout cela avec manuel
tissier signé plabennec les joueurs
bretons réalisent l'exploit du week-end
18e du national soit la troisième
division
plabennec élimine ogc nice de la coupe
de france sur un terrain fraîchement
déneiger nice avait pourtant ouvert la
marque par loïc rémy mais dans le temps
additionnel de la première période
plabennec frappe deux fois d'abord par
son capitaine jean michel abiven
plus un but contre son camp du niçois
gérald cid pour ce coup le ballon
franchit à peine la ligne mais cela
suffit pour enflammer le vestiaire du
finistère-nord pas de liesse en revanche
à trélissac l'om s'est imposé 2 à 0
notamment grâce à ce petit coup de patte
de benarfa et un autre but de cheyrou
sourire étincelant julien lizeroux lance
enfin son univers le français remporte
le slalom d'adelboden
le vice champion du monde a livré en
suisse une deuxième manche
exceptionnelle
seulement 12e de la première il s'impose
pour la troisième fois de sa carrière
ça valait bien un cri de joueurs aussi
autre piste autres latitudes la 8e étape
du dakar au chili a sacré un régional le
motard chilien lopez contardo s'impose
chez lui le français cyril depres et
reste en tête du classement général moto
le cinéma avec tout d'abord le box
office des sorties cinéma de cette
semaine en tête un film français le
siffleur une comédie avec thierry
lhermitte françois berléand et fred
testot ensuite agora une plongée dans
les gîtes du vème siècle après
jésus-christ avec rachel weisz et enfin
bright star le dernier film de jane
campion réalisatrice de la leçon de
piano
notre grand format ce soir avec un film
pour l'histoire mercredi sort dans les
salles le dernier film de clint eastwood
film consacré au destin de nelson
mandela il nous raconte comment le
président sud africain a fait de
l'équipe nationale de rugby un symbole
de la réconciliation nationale au tour
sur la fiction et sur l'histoire la
vraie avec pascal deschamps regardez le
président sud africain nelson mandela
serrant la main du capitaine des
springboks ce un jour de juin 1995 c'est
peu de dire que cette scène était
inimaginable en afrique du sud
quelques mois plus tôt en racontant
l'histoire d'une victoire
clint eastwood ne raconte pas seulement
un exploit sportif
il reconstitue fidèlement une page
d'histoire l'improbable réconciliation
des ennemis d'hier grâce à la vision de
cet homme mandela interprété par morgan
freeman
ce n'était pas un match de rugby c'était
un événement historique
si l'on en croit les spécialistes nous
irons en quarts des neuf et pas au delà
non
les spécialistes vous et moi devrions
être encore en prison
tout le monde disait t'as mandela mais
pourquoi vous vous intéressez au rugby
de toute façon ils ont pernes ça ne vous
rapportera rien et c'est lui qui avait
raison
il en a fait un véritable enjeu car
lorsque mandela arrive au pouvoir
le pays est déchiré parmi les symboles
de l'apartheid
l'équipe de rugby les springboks
l'équipe des blancs quand les noirs se
déplaçait enfermés derrière des
grillages
c'était pour soutenir l'équipe adverse
la première décision du comité des
sports et de supprimer les springbocks
mandela s'y opposent
ils sont nos compatriotes sud africain
nos partenaires dans une démocratie et
ils chérissent leur équipe des freebox
si nous leur enlevant sa nous les
perdons en soutenant les springboks et
demandé l' élite balayé les peurs des
blancs de la minorité blanche white les
blancs étaient terrifiés ils pensaient
que le pays était au bord de la guerre
civile
brewer l'autre artisan de cette fois
l'entreprise c'est le capitaine de
l'équipe françois pinard issu d'une
famille trop apartheid il va être
littéralement conquis par mandela
d'eads mois font ce qu est ce qui peut
nous espérer et nous pousser vers
l'excellence quand on n'a pas du tout
joué
comment peut-on motivé tout ce qui nous
entoure
qu'est ce qu'il voulait je crois qu'il
veut qu'on gagne a coutume les
springboks se retrouvent en finale au et
dès l'arrivée dans le stade tout sentent
que quelque chose a changé
le garde du corps de mandela se souvient
owens et on t'attend mandela est entré
sur le terrain il ya onze lammer je me
suis dit 'c'est passageoise mandela
flammes et par des blancs
c'est en effet une première même émotion
du côté des joueurs lorsqu'ils
découvrent que le président portent leur
maillot les gars ont eu les larmes aux
yeux
il avait même des joueurs qui fleurait
aucun d'entre nous n'imaginait que monde
et la porterez notre maillot et ça nous
apporte et devrait être face et au coup
de sifflet final
tous les protagonistes ont conscience
d'avoir vécu un moment capital pour le
pays et lorsque le commentateur officiel
dit à françois pinard que son équipe a
été soutenue par les soixante cinq mille
supporteurs présents par 65000 sud
américain mais par 43 millions de sud
africains
j'ai fait un rêve aurait pu lire mandela
invictus est l'histoire de ce rêve de
ses rêves dont les nations ont aussi
besoin pour grandir
un mot de musique on a appris
aujourd'hui la mort du chanteur mano
solo mort à l'âge de 46 ans
il souffrait du sida depuis de
nombreuses années il avait une voix
déchirante un talent multiple
il aimait le tango la poésie le dessin
il était encore en concert à l'olympia
le 12 novembre dernier
mano solo qui parlait également toujours
clairement et sincèrement écouter nos
solo c'est un peu ça c'est à dire que
personne me sortir de mon merdias par
mois moi je veux rappeler aux gens
aujourd'hui que tout ce qu'on a à chuter
à gagner à aujourd'hui à se shooter
c'est super sida ou ou facile toute
manière c'est une perte de temps que
c'est ça j'ai envie de dire aux gens et
surtout aux jeunes penser que c'est
vraiment une perte de temps de se
défoncer la gueule aujourd'hui
je prendrais sans dans les joues roses
d'impôts
qui allez on y croit
voilà mano solo mort à l'âge de 46 ans
comme chaque dimanche voici et
maintenant l'agenda de la semaine à
venir l'ensemble de la classe politique
rendre hommage demain à philippe séguin
lors d'une cérémonie d'hommage aux
invalides côté nicolas sarkozy les
anciens présidents jacques chirac et
valéry giscard d'estaing dès mardi vous
pourrez vous faire vacciner contre la
grippe a par votre médecin traitant et
puis dimanche prochain une visite
importante celle du pape benoît 16 à la
synagogue de rome
et cela alors que sa décision de
poursuivre le processus de béatification
de pie xii reste controversée et puis
une pensée pour les proches de la
famille de vos ni guillot qui nous a
quittés elle était une figure de la
rédaction d'antenne 2 elle a travaillé
avec armand jammot daniel bilalian bruno
masure elle travailla également à la
radio on l'a surnommé la voix d'or
d'europe 1 vonny dio est décédé des
suites d'un cancer
voilà fin de ce journal merci à vous de
m'avoir suivi tout de suite ne manquez
pas la météo d'isabel martinez 20h35 un
classique
les choristes avec gérard jugnot
françois berléand et kad merad demain
d'information c'est dès 6h30 dans
télématin avec sophie le saint 13h elise
lucet et à 20h david pujadas excellente
fin de week-end et bonne soirée à vous